[Music]
a huge shipment of 20 000 coconuts
filled with
what cocaine
holy [ __ ] you heard about this huh no
coconuts cocaine it just felt good
together
white coco
all right well that's the that's the
video
oh [ __ ] i was right you get to like the
video like the video subscribe
thank you very much thanks for being a
super sleuth
we never tell them to subscribe and
comment you guys should subscribe and
comment i think they're already
subscribed
smash the like button yeah we have to
say it that's what youtubers do that's
what the tubers are notification bell
click the notifications
like this video in like how long i don't
even know
like it please if you guys please like
it thank you this one on the other ones
if you can all the ones that you did
watch and you forgot you can like they
can't like of course you can everyone
can you just [ __ ] hit click the
button
click the button we'll go back to some
of your favorites and like it if you
haven't yet because that'll actually be
worth it yeah all right
so the video is really over
[Music]
yes
so yeah 20 000 coconuts were filled with
liquid cocaine holy [ __ ] liquid cocaine
cocaine and it was discovered at a porch
in route to italy
how did they find it did they crack the
[ __ ] coconut open and they go up oh
yeah that's cocaine well they found
coconuts hidden in 500 canvas bags and
this is all in colombia right so they're
like okay well this is you know about to
head out to italy so we're just going to
inspect them we do we do standard
inspection but upon upon
inspection it was established that the
water in the fruit had been exchanged
for liquid cocaine
so they sent the coconuts to a lab to
establish the exact amount of cocaine
that they have they're also
investigating exactly where the coconuts
were loaded who was going to receive
them
etc
and one of the big one of the biggest
way the method to do this right is you
dissolve cocaine into water to disguise
its appearance that everyone's just like
it's just [ __ ] coconut coconut water
yeah and then you swap the water in
coconuts for diluted uh cocaine
and then do you do you then like [ __ ]
process it when you're done dry it and
then it becomes all powder again uh
they're not trying to give us the method
anthony they're trying to keep the
method a secret i'm trying to learn the
methods so i can
why don't we become a narc they said
whenever they catch these things i wish
they would tell the public how many
times they've gotten away with it prior
yeah
now do you guys have awesome smuggling
stories smuggling stories have you ever
smuggled drugs
what's smuggling i smuggle snacks into a
movie theater i'm pretty good at that
dude i used to pack my dad used to have
me wear a leather jacket and then we
would [ __ ] pack the sleeves with like
skittles and all kinds of sit on your
shoulders yeah and i don't even eat
candy but my brothers and sisters would
eat it so i would just pack the [ __ ]
it's just a candy mule thing
you're just duct taping a [ __ ] like
whoppers around you
is it taped to you and you know i'm tall
so you know it wasn't that hard to
believe that you know i'm also yoked as
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
remember that scene in um wolf of wall
street when they're trying to move that
cash and [ __ ] and it's just like
what the hell do i do
man
you ever thought about like what you
would do if you just had cash like that
you had to move
like how would you do it
what's what's the method what's the name
and how much give us a scenario
all right let's let's say like a million
dollars in cash that's it that's not
that much you can fill a [ __ ] like a
definite one dollars one point one
dollar but you're trying to fit a
million through the [ __ ] like airport
i don't know what a million dollars in
cash looks like a million holy [ __ ] but
what depending on the amount though is
five dollars jumped through bigger and
bigger like okay let's say let's say
this much cash physically this much cash
whatever this much is it could be in
ones it could be oh okay yes it's a lot
okay it's this much cash 300 you don't
know what to do with that if it's ones
i'm gonna get it converted to hundreds
first so it's smaller no no you gotta go
through ones
oh yeah or if it's ones i do twos and
then that goes
at least half well through customs right
two dollars ah it's a hundreds okay okay
hundreds
all right
and you gotta get it to another
destination because you have a friend at
a bank that will secretly put it in for
you across the ocean or the land use the
mode of transportation or you could
choose any transportation and get a boat
yeah but it's over it's
yes
you got okay just just like you got land
options you got sea options you got air
options
but
it's going from one country to another
country so you gotta watch out for the
military i guess my biggest question is
why does this country need a bunch of
two dollar bills
it's a hundred now it's in circulation
you gotta put in the second let's say
you're gonna watch the money we're going
from
colombia colombia to the united states
so you can't go by land you can buy land
you can but you have the threat of the
cartels i don't know you have the threat
of the governments and you have the
threat of the armies i take the money i
turn it into cocaine put it in water and
put it in coconuts
that's happened before
so
so they they found uh using airport
scanners right they showed the unusual
density inside the coconuts and a small
hole was bored and they were obviously
they injected someone's doing their job
what the [ __ ]
i hate it when they do this what if you
did it with like cases of water bottles
that are like maybe a sports drink or
something like this
yeah maybe and then you you ship that
through with a liquid cocaine do you
think that would work well i think they
use coconuts because it's
less uh conspicuous
you know when you see like whole fruits
whole foods you're like i just get these
[ __ ] chickens through you don't think
every single chicken has a bag of
cocaine stuff in there you really think
something is when it's fish because they
always use fish right it was like remove
the top layer of fish and there's a
giant case there yeah i figured it out i
know how i'm going to move that cash how
you gonna do it it's it's gonna work 100
i'm gonna say i'm a company that makes
prop money and then just write film use
only on every bill
you know what i do how do you wash it
off they're going to scan it though the
second they scan the barcode of the the
bill and then i do a little extra line
or two on each bar yeah
this is why you suck at being a criminal
all right oh [ __ ] here's the easiest
thing you do i wanted to use it moving
it all right true
you buy an airplane
for
a million two million
did you spend all the money no play
problem solve wait a point buy an
airplane you wouldn't lose [ __ ] then you
can move a million dollars oh [ __ ] and
then you fly that [ __ ] to where you
need to go and then you sell it well
that's that's what they do i mean i'm
giving away a lot of [ __ ] secrets
here but for china
when uh some of the people that work in
china that are dancers do it that's how
you do it you just buy watches you buy a
bunch of like [ __ ] you know you can
resell yeah you get here and just sell
it
yeah
a lot of people do that that's pretty
sweet that's why there's a lot of
foreign investments in america
i think you just gave away all the big
secrets there
i mean that's a pretty [ __ ]
everyone knows that right come on pretty
much
i like the taking this stack
and then buying a plane so the stack is
gone
and then selling a used plane for way
back the plane
it's like new it's low miles it's like
new come on i'm not gonna lose that much
then you buy something else that's worth
100 that's worth 500 000 and then you
sell that for a little bit less too
because you use that
you bought like a little boat but then
you had to use it to get like back to
america and then like everyone's like i
don't know it's kind of used like
that three thousand trying to move money
it's kind of used
trying to move money's like an art it is
an art man i can help you guys but
nobody comes to me for the ideas
[Laughter]
bioplane all right what about drugs
let's talk about drugs you take the
drugs right
and then you sell it for a plane
yeah okay
okay
okay so it's pretty transferable you can
do this with anything you do all the
drugs so it's in your system what if you
got a smuggle over it and then you put
it on you throw it up
yeah i mean what what do you want with
the drugs you want to sell it or you
want to smuggle it smuggle you want the
drugs intact
wow you're making a lot of sacrifices to
you up to you up to you okay you're
gonna turn into a plane
[Laughter]
you sell the drug you're gonna turn into
a plan you're an anamorph okay
that needs to be sold for a plane
sell the drugs
buy the plane
okay nobody
cause you can already sell it in the
native country i mean
12 forces on this and every course is
like so not that you want to move that
money into a plane
the final goal was to sell the drugs
over in this country so you sell it in
this country first
only to get them back in this i just
love how easy that's just one step yeah
sell the drugs buy the plane fly over
sell the plane buy the drugs sell the
drugs buy the plane drug dealers are
dumb dude and then you safely laundered
a plane hello you stupid [ __ ] now it's
not a drug plane anymore got it it's a
clean plane joe is just a plain mogul
dude it's washed yeah
it's a wash you're going to be the
richard branson drop the serial number
on the plane
[Laughter]
you guys are stupid
joe how are you only worth 500 000
dollars as well i don't know either
that's celebrity network you know why
because he has all his net worth in
planes
you know what they should have googled
him last year he was worth 750 000
oh it's because all my money is made
illegally
you